one guy who says that he will be showing
up for the start of training camp as
falcons receiver julio jones now the
falcons report on the 21st so that's
just a few days away they're getting
ready to face the broncos in the hall of
fame game they get extra time for
training camp but that shortens the
deadline for when jones needs to be
there and more importantly when the
falcons need to get a deal done with
jones and look what the falcons have
done recently they did a beat the clock
deal with grady jarrett on monday before
the deadline came and went for signing
franchise tag players to long-term deals
and then on wednesday dion jones gets a
new contract so
does julio jones get his new contract
before the 21st he has he has said hey
arthur blank the owner of the team has
given me his word that we're going to
get this done well it's one thing for
the falcons to want to get it done it's
another thing for the falcons to give in
to whatever it is that julio jones wants
and and that's the bottom line here it's
not a blank check hey yeah we'll gladly
sign you to a new contract
if you accept our terms but we're not
going to give in to what you want simply
because you want that much money we want
to give you a new deal you don't want to
take the deal we want to give you so
let's keep an eye on this one last year
remember it looked like julio jones was
going to hold out they moved some money
around to placate him but the thinking
always was by this year he would get
that next contract and the challenge for
the falcons is very simple the falcons
know that they've probably already
gotten the best of julio jones so
how much do you pay a guy
for what he's already done that runs
counter to everything we've heard about
the nfl in the last 25 years with the
advent of the salary cap and free agency
the nfl became a what have you done for
me lately league or more accurately what
are you doing for me right now and what
can i expect you to do for me tomorrow
that's what teams pay for
julio jones i think to a certain degree
wants to get paid for past performance
wants to get paid for the fact that
maybe he hasn't gotten paid as much as
he should have gotten paid during those
years where he was truly in his prime
now look he may still be very well in
his prime he could be the best receiving
the nfl this season but
he's getting closer and closer to the
edge of the cliff
and the falcons don't want to put
themselves in position where they have
paid a ton of money to a guy who isn't
performing up to
that dollar figure that julio jones
apparently wants so we'll see in the
next few days whether or not they get
that deal done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports